welcome back to 8701
so in this uh video we want to look at
experimental studies of neutrino
oscillations
the first question is where do we get
the neutrinos how do we produce the
neutrinos the answer is
there's numerous sources for neutrinos
you might be lucky and
find them in supernova explosions or
if you're really trying hard we can
observe them as relics
of the big bang there is a lot of
neutrinos as
as the relic of the big bang um around
us
the problem is that they have very low
energies and are difficult to observe
um easier so is the use of neutrinos
when they're
generated in cosmic air showers
there's a lot of neutrinos coming from
the sun
beams beam lines accelerators can be
used
to smash particles into material and
then in the decay product produce also
neutrinos
and also reactors nuclear reactors can
be used as neutrino sources
by the way neutrinos can also be used in
order to
monitor the nuclear activity
around the globe
okay studies of neutrino oscillation so
we can make this table here
and ask ourselves what kind of you know
the experimental parameters are the
length the energy
and the sensitivity to specific mass
range
so for the solar neutrinos you know the
distance between the earth and the sun
is pretty much fixed
um to first order the energy of the
neutrinos coming out is in the order of
one mav we are going to look at a table
and so the mass range you can probe is
10 to the minus 10
in delta m square for atmospheric
neutrinos they are produced in the upper
atmosphere
you know tend to the forge 10 to the 7
meters energies can range at a large
range
let's say 10 to the 2 to 10 to the 5 mb
and then reactors typically mav range
this is kind of the nuclear range for
for neutrino energies
um and the range is given by you know
how much space do you have
you know around or away from a nuclear
reactor
similarly for accelerators you build an
accelerator or
use an existing accelerator and then you
build your detectors
maybe close to it and maybe another one
far away and that's limited by the size
of our planet
or wherever you want to build um
build your detectors energy ranges there
depends on the energy range of the
accelerator
and that is in the in the order of 10 to
the 3 10 to the five
four maybe so you see that
you know it's actually rather
straightforward study
also it's interesting to see and we see
this next what kind of
flavor of neutrinos and whether or not
we can
study neutrinos or anti-neutrinos
without the experiment is important
so let's go through this and also
explain a little bit of a history and
how this all occurred
so the first question is you know what
what happens to the solar neutrinos
so solar neutrinos are basically
produced in the core of the sun together
with light
it turns out that the light of the sun
takes about 10 000 years to come out of
the sun while the neutrinos come out
immediately so when
first experiments tried to observe
solar neutrinos they had to
theoretically estimate and how many
neutrinos to expect
and they saw less and so one explanation
would have been or could have been or
was
uh maybe something happened at the core
of the sun and we just haven't seen it
yet because
the light which comes out of the sun you
know has a delay of
up to ten thousand years that didn't
turn out to be the case
um so here's the spectrum of the
neutrino energies and the specific
sources of neutrinos
uh from the sun in our nuclear physics
discussion we
will get to the point that we understand
how the neutrino
how the sun produces energy and then
some of this becomes more clear
the story to take away at this point is
that there certain there's
several processes within the sun
producing neutrinos
and they all come with a characteristic
energy distribution
um but the bottom line is you know you
find mav scale neutrinos from the sun
so there's a soup of electron neutrinos
um they start interacting with the sun
and there's a little bit of a flavor
evolution
within when they go through the material
of the sun
um but you know what you want to really
do
is you know look for disappearance in
detectors which are sensitive to
electron neutrinos and that has been
done um
in a number of experiments most famous
maybe the davis experiments which
the big tank of chlorine and in the
interaction you were looking for
finding argon in your detector and you
just every now and then went in there
and saw how much argon was actually
produced
and it turned out that those experiments
all of them found
a reduced number of neutrinos
reduced with respect to the theoretical
expectation
so far so good
[Music]
the assumption was that or there was no
knowledge of neutrino
oscillations or mixing at this time so
that needed to be explained and one way
to explain but it's not just using the
charge interaction which allows you
to probe the flavor of the neutrino but
also lose the neutral
um the neutral scattering
which then allows you to measure the
total number of neutrinos
and if you do this this was done by the
snow experiment you find that the total
number of neutrinos
is in good agreement with the
theoretical expectation
hence the neutrinos are not really lost
they're just more from one flavor into
the next
so this was the first evidence for um
for uh solar neutrinos to be um
oscillator uh by now this you know this
first experiment was
homestake um but now there is a larger
number of solar neutrino experiments
when you see
it's a long time of neutrino studies
different materials are being used
different energy thresholds being tested
different scale of the experiments
and experiments become more sensitive
the larger they are
and so this is can some something you
can see from this table
the next source of neutrinos is the ones
which are produced in the atmosphere
so they are produced in the case of
pions and k ons
and you know while the cosmic rays
interact with
the atmosphere or the earth's atmosphere
and so you find for example a pi plus
decaying into a muon in a neuron
neutrino and then the muon itself
can decay into an electron an electron
neutrino and a muon antineutrino
so if you for example build the ratio of
neuron
antimen over electron
anti-electroneutrinos
you find it should be around two
right you have two neutrino neutrinos
here and then electro nitrogen
and also this wasn't really um
really observed and you can see here as
a function of the cosine of the
need you know looking up upwards towards
the atmosphere or downwards you find
that there is an effect
of of this kind of oscillation
so the actual minimum measurement
depends on the energy range
um and you can see that the neural
neutrinos
neuron like neutrinos that disappear you
see here in this very clear plot
the prediction without oscillation
compared to the experimental results so
you see
the mirror neutrinos actually disappear
moving on accelerators can be used and
the big accelerator on the earth
are cern or fermilab the beam line its
thermolab is called lumi
national accelerator laboratory um
or cern or in japan
those are the big sources of accelerated
driven arduinos
and in resource there's an
big detectors typically the detector
very close
to the accelerator and one further away
the close one to probe the
total flux of the neutrino at the
experiment and then the
one which is away in order to probe the
effect of the neutrino oscillation
now in order to study appearance or
disappearance
and again here you see this is a long
program but it basically took off quite
a bit
in the 2000s and after so a lot of
neutrino physics happened in those years
a lot of information about the neutrino
was gathered in this year
and again here this is from the t2k
experiment
you see the comparison between
unoscillated predictions and oscillated
you know using some additional
constraints about your expectation of
the total flux of the neutrinos
and that compared to the data and you
see very clearly that the
the neutrinos oscillate that there is
evidence for oscillation
all right the last source on reactor
neutrinos
we'll talk about nuclear physics
starting from next week
here neutrinos are produced in nuclear
fission of heavy isotopes
mainly that's uranium and polonium
flux can be calculated in various ways
for example
by knowing the nuclear processes and
internal
thermal power produced in the reactor
or by just looking at how much fuel is
being nuclear fuel is being
used by the reactor itself what's being
started here is the anti
um anti-electronic treated disappearance
and you what you do here is use this
inverse bitter decay where you have a
collision
or scattering of a anti-electro neutrino
with a proton
creating an electron a positron and a
neutron
and again there's a number of
experiments basically whenever you have
a
[Music]
whenever you have a large
neutrino experiment it can probe
surrounding nuclear reactors there's
many of them
in france in japan also in china
and they're being used in those
experiments again you see that this
topic became really hot
in the 2000s and again a lot of a lot
has been there and learned
so this part here shows you as a
function of the energy the length over
the energy
so kilometer over meb the oscillation
the survival probability meaning that
you can actually see directly the
oscillation of energy